so we had this long period of basically
complete silence on the congressman matt
gates investigation and possible
forthcoming charges then last week we
learned that matt gates ex-girlfriend
had testified before a grand jury and
now things moving significantly more
quickly we have learned that matt gates
ex-girlfriend has been granted immunity
in the sex trafficking probe
investigating the congressman so let's
kind of back it up and reset the entire
thing i believe it was in march of 2021
i remember where where i was we were on
break that week
news uh broke
that matt gates was being investigated
for a number of possible crimes matt
gates is the radical trumpian republican
congressman from florida he's an
absolutely horrible extremist
in every sense of the word and in every
sense of the uh
of of
every aspect of him falls under that
category the charges that were being
looked at and remember he has not been
charged with anything yet
that's sort of the whole point of this
it includes
charges stemming from possible actions
involving paying people for money
and the transportation of underage women
between states which would make it a
sex trafficking case and then as we
expected charges any day
basically nothing happened he did lawyer
up hiring some of the best sex crime
lawyers in the country
but nothing happened and many of you
started to email me asking what's going
on with that is the story dead and of
course i don't know
last week we learned that matt gates
ex-girlfriend testified before a grand
jury and this was one of the first
recent signals that this thing is not
only still going on but could be getting
very serious and now we have learned
that matt gates ex-girlfriend has been
granted immunity in the sex trafficking
probe now there are a number of
different takeaways from this which
we're going to talk about but as cbs
news reports prosecutors granted
immunity to an ex-girlfriend of
representative matt gates before she
testified last week in front of a
federal grand jury gates has been under
investigation to determine if he
violated sex trafficking laws
and obstructed justice in that probe
gates has previously denied all
wrongdoing and has said that he has
never paid for sex nor had sex with an
underage girl the woman who cbs news is
not naming testified last wednesday she
is viewed as a potential key witness
according to two sources one of the
sources said she has information related
to the investigation of both the sex
trafficking and obstruction allegations
cbs news legal analyst ricky clyman says
quote this may be a willing participant
who has a smart lawyer who sought an
immunity deal from the government the
government does not give immunity
blindly so they know what they are
getting in exchange also
the government
or in general people typically don't ask
for immunity unless they were involved
in wrongdoing in some way
and the
hypothetical that's being laid out is
that in florida failure to report child
abuse is a crime
and
this is all speculative but
what we're what is being kind of
discussed is
if part of her testimony
is that she knew of underage
victims as what they are legally of matt
gates
and she didn't report them
she could theoretically be liable for
that because of florida law because in
florida everybody's considered a
mandatory a mandated reporter if she
knew about that she should have reported
it and so the most kind of benign
interpretation of the immunity thing
would be that's what it's about she knew
about it and she's only now talking
about it and she could be liable
obviously it could be far worse than
that in terms of the involvement of matt
gates ex-girlfriend we just don't know
at this point in time but that is what
what's being speculated so this is not
only still going on but it is very very
serious um isabelle kirschner who's one
of these top sex crime defense lawyers
an attorney for gates said to cbs quote
we have seen no credible basis for a
charge against gates
we remain steadfast in our commitment to
challenge any allegations with the facts
and law a source told cbs that as part
of an obstruction probe investigators
are looking into whether gates had a
phone call with the ex-girlfriend and
another woman who was already a witness
in the federal investigation sources
told cbs that the ex-girlfriend and the
other woman traveled to the bahamas with
gates in 2018 along with a third woman
with whom gates was in a sexual
relationship that third woman was 18 but
investigators are looking into whether
she was 17
when the sexual relationship began which
would be very bad for matt gates
investigators are also trying to
determine if any of the women were paid
and were illegally trafficked across
state or international lines for the
purpose of sex with the congressman you
know uh sort of like common sense
suggests to us
that matt gates shouldn't be such a
compelling person for women to be with
that if he's traveling to the bahamas
with three women one of them was
probably compensated to do it it is you
know we think about it and we go well
it's tough to imagine if you're the
third woman going to the bahamas with
matt gates on some kind of sex trip that
you're doing it willingly but you have
to remember uh 300 million people in
this country matt gates
in some some very general sense seeing
as a guy you know with power and access
to power and at the time had a
relationship with donald trump and
whatever we shouldn't write off the
possibility that someone might have done
this without getting paid but obviously
when you read about it it's sort of like
matt gates what what on earth is going
on here it is increasingly looking like
there is going to be a legal problem for
matt gates coming here and the latest is
immunity for the ex-girlfriend you know
just yesterday we talked about
the definition of freedom that the right
adheres to right now
is very authoritarian the freedom to
deny other people things the freedom to
tell others what it is they can and
can't do the freedom you know we talked
about that yesterday
um there's another element to this
authoritarian slide that i think
deserves its own discussion which is
that the republican party is moving in
the direction of pulling out of future
presidential debates the republican
national committee says it will require
candidates to pledge to not participate
in debates run by the commission on
presidential debates what would replace
them if anything was unclear
this is an extraordinarily authoritarian
move now there's sort of like the
logical reason why they would do this
and then there's the reality that it
fits into this bigger authoritarian
picture and we'll go through both of
those aspects in a second the new york
times reporter maggie haberman reported
the rnc is preparing to change its rules
to require presidential candidates that
want to be a republican nominee to
pledge not to participate in what have
historically been the official
presidential debates
sponsored by the commission on
presidential debates republican
committee officials
alerted the debate commission to their
plans in a letter sent thursday
if the change goes forward it would be
one of the most substantial shifts in
how presidential and vice presidential
debates have been conducted since the
commission began organizing debates more
than 30 years ago the nonprofit
commission was founded by the two
parties in 1987. it codified debates as
a permanent part of presidential
elections describes itself as
nonpartisan republicans have complained
for a decade that the process favored
democrats
the move by the rnc was an outgrowth of
those long held complaints and came
after months of discussions between the
commission and party officials
this discussion apparently started last
year the republican party chairwoman
ronald mcdaniel demanded changes be made
to how debates were held the change
requiring candidates to refuse
participation is to be voted on at the
rnc winter meeting in february if they
move forward it's unclear what that
means for future debates so there are
two pieces to this okay first let's talk
about the sort of like well yeah
if you have no issue based platform on
which you would debate why would you
debate and what i mean by that is
increasingly
started with i mean listen i'm not going
to do the whole thing but it this
started a really long time ago but more
acutely
george w bush became less and less issue
focused and more kind of ideology based
when barack obama became president
republicans went completely crazy and
abandoned policy 90 percent and then
under trump there's been no more policy
at all if you don't have policy on which
to debate why would you go to a debate
okay that that sort of makes sense but
then it goes further
if you're not trying to win on the
issues
right if you're winning on trying to win
on gerrymandering voter suppression
bogus post-election tactics legal
challenges and the like
debates don't really have a part in that
you don't really need to convince people
to vote for you
and the third piece of this is that this
is very on brand in terms of being
autocratic and authoritarian and former
david pakman show guest ruth ben giat
wrote a really good piece in her sub
stack called demagogues don't debate
the gop mimics putin and orban refusing
to participate in presidential debates
is a symptom of the republicans embrace
of authoritarianism this is a really
good article to check out a good blog
post from ruth ben giat
who writes debates between presidential
candidates enact the democratic
principle of mutual tolerance the notion
that those who don't share your
political views have a right to free
expression the public hears an exchange
of views by two individuals on equal
footing bound by the same rules and
forced by an impartial arbiter when they
say we're not going to do that anymore
it furthers this idea that number one
they people with political disagreements
can't even be in the same room as each
other
but also
uh is the uh furtherance of other
aspects of authoritarianism personality
cults as ruth bengiat writes posit the
leader as a man above all others the
egalitarian staging and format of
debates makes them dangerous to his
brand since authoritarians sustain power
through disinformation threat corruption
and fixing elections who knows what
might be exposed if they submit to
spontaneous questioning by a rival or a
third party and that is a fundamental
aspect of this
and i won't read ruth's entire post but
she talks about putin understanding this
and his history of refusing to debate
and talks about orban a putin client who
has followed that lead orban hasn't
debated since 16 years ago
after a really bad performance in a 2006
debate so there's two aspects of this
and there's the
they don't run on policy so why even
talk to the opposition sure that's fair
but then there's also yet another way
in this which
in which this idea of not getting on
stage with your opponent
mimics and mirrors that which we've seen
other authoritarian strong men do uh
around the world over the last 20 years
so very much on brand with this extreme
authoritarian
dictatorial slide that we've seen from
the republican party the republican
party will vote next month as to whether
they are finalizing this decision not to
participate in the debates
my instinct is they're going to do it
i don't think this you know it seems
like the type of thing they would kind
of decide beforehand do we have the
votes for it uh but we'll see next month
and we'll tell you when there is an
ultimate uh decision made by them in the
meantime you can let me know your
thoughts about this
wildly autocratic decision uh by finding
me on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
our program is mostly funded by viewers
and listeners through the david pakman
show membership page which you can find
at
joinpacman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members and i would love it
if you signed up at joinpakman.com
the latest bogus covid treatment slash
prophylactic slash cure
it's all of the above in reality it's
none
is inhaling hydrogen peroxide through an
asthma nebulizer now i'm going to say it
a number of times throughout this
segment to remain in compliance this is
a bad idea
not evidence-based not recommended by
actual doctors and can be very harmful
to your health so don't
nebulize hydrogen peroxide through
asthma inhalers i'm merely telling you
that there are people doing it
last week we talked about so-called
urine therapy
which involves
drinking urine
rubbing it on your skin
uh using it in a neti pot you know it's
it does not do anything for covid
despite what that crazy guy i told you
about last week says the new one is
inhaling
uh aerosolized i guess we would call it
hydrogen peroxide
this is wildly spreading
and uh i it's crazy because we we had
this long weekend
i check back in on the news when we get
back from the long weekend
and all of a sudden hydrogen peroxide
inhalation
is everywhere so here's
one guy explaining
how the
hydrogen peroxide protects him not only
from covid but from people shedding
vaccine on him which is a whole other
insane widely debunked thing and again
as a pre-disclaimer
essentially nothing that you're going to
hear in this clip is uh accurate so
let's take a listen
there's been a lot of articles saying oh
this is terrible for you don't ever do
this don't ever
inhale uh nebulized hydroperoxide but
hydra peroxide
if a doctor is going to go on and
actually say to do this
you know i trust in the one doctor
again i forget his name but uh i'll post
the video there's one doctor who is
saying to do this and the guy doesn't
remember that doctor's name but all the
other ones are saying don't he trusts
the one doctor whose name he doesn't
remember theo's
mercola has a conversation with him
um in uh
rumble and by the way anytime you hear
the name dr mercola head for the hills
folks they're also on bed shoot where
they talk about the guys been [ __ ]
shoot what on earth is happening doing
this since the 90s now he also utilizes
uh
iodine um puts like a drop
the iodine thing also was floating
around a few months ago that's totally
debunked as well dying into the into the
medicine bottle here
i haven't tried that yet i'm going to
try it uh i'm actually got someone order
and see
the iodine that they're recommending i
think is
it costs like nine bucks for two little
doesn't this guy just inspire confidence
in terms of medical treatments roles or
something like that so
again there are different ways to do it
but i find that this is the easiest way
plus you got it like you know in the
fridge and it's ready to go so whenever
i go to a rally or i'm going to a
restaurant or i went to the movies the
other night and stuff like that
and you know i don't ever wear a mask so
uh right not that they help but i the
first thing i do is i come in and i put
one of these on isn't that brilliant he
says i do this because i don't ever wear
a mask even though the masks don't help
well then why do you need to do
something in lieu of wearing a mask like
ev you could analyze every sentence and
it wouldn't make any sense
also
i don't have to wait for that to be
honest with you uh when i get up in the
morning i do this
and since then i haven't been taken any
antihistamines
uh anything like that i haven't been
taking any cold medication i haven't had
any like congestion um my sleep has been
a lot better
um i i i and i attributed to this now as
i want to point something out as a va
and he says this is the only thing that
i've done this he attributes it to this
any time this this starts this is a very
common thing in general in the kind of
quack cures thing
which is
they start to tell you it basically
cures and treats everything you know and
this has been floating around for a long
time and it's everything from you know
you can find that drinking colloidal
silver it's basically it treats
everything or
pomegranate or any time something treats
so many conditions and and deals with so
many symptoms aside from the fact that
this is not a medical professional
we should all be skeptical and really
different so
um nebulizer unless it's like you know
maintaining a regimen of a good diet
exercise going outside every single day
it's like yes that all together that
entire lifestyle
is good for a lot of different things
but whenever it's like
hydrogen peroxide treats all these
things we should be very skeptical 80
bucks 90 with tax
uh i would say eight to ten dollars for
for the food grade 12 hydrogen peroxide
for 100 bucks i think it's it's worth it
and again like i said i
i went to the movies the other night in
pasadena you don't have to show a vax
card and we didn't wear masks and uh
we're in the
you know in there with a bunch of you
know backstop people shedding all over
us and everything like that even though
they got masks going i put you know
first thing i did as soon as i got home
as i uh hit this takes about 10 minutes
to to go to the end here
and you can watch tv while you're doing
it it's not that intrusive so he's using
it interesting to protect himself not
only from the virus but also from
vaccine shedding which again we've
debunked all of this so do not inhale
hydrogen peroxide okay health line has
published extensively on this um it can
hurt your lungs it won't prevent covid
um there is a quote from
uh the aafa which is the asthma and
allergy foundation of america they said
hydrogen peroxide can be used as a
cleaner and stain remover and can cause
tissue damage if you swallow it or
breathe it in
dr len horvitz who's a nationally
recognized pulmonary specialist
said um that this could seriously harm
people
quote the very beginning of this let's
talk about things that are ridiculous
way back in march of 2020 i had a
patient send me something from what
seemed to be a scientific study that
explained the virus is inactivated by
heat and suggested putting a hair dryer
up to your nose five minutes every day
maybe they were just trying to sell hair
dryers don't do this guys it's
extraordinarily dangerous it's a very
very bad idea and what's endlessly
fascinating as a sort of detached
observer
is they seem determined
to try anything
other than the vaccine which we know is
very likely to keep you out of serious
covid
anything else they'll try iodine
hair dryer up your nose
nebulized hydrogen peroxide urine
therapy
but we've got the vaccine it's fda
approved it works really well at
preventing serious illness and yet that
they don't seem to want it's truly
incredible it's like they're determined
to thin themselves out either by getting
coveted and dying
or by using dangerous so-called
treatments which are not actually
treatments and again just as a reminder
this is an unproven treatment that
shouldn't be called a treatment that can
hurt you so do not nebulize hydrogen
peroxide
we've had a lot of these different
stories
of casually anti-vaccine people
dying of covet and these are stories
that are very controversial within even
my audience about should we feel
sympathy should we feel glee should we
feel both should we feel neither or
whatever the case may be
we now have a story of a very well-known
long-time anti-vaccine leader
who has died of covid this is an italian
individual named luigi marilli
all of the articles about him almost all
the articles that i found are in italian
so we're looking at a translation on
reddit about this
and uh as the story goes luigi marilli
63 the leader of the novak's movement in
abruzzo
died after suffering from covid
remember that there is a significant
anti-vaxx movement in italy italy has we
we talked about this predating covid
when it came to measles big problem in
parts of italy
the activist died in the hospital where
he was hospitalized he was the
territorial representative for his
region of liberiamo litalia and was
among the first to fight the war against
vaccines and the green pass obligation
he had been living in abruzzo for some
time
was always in the front line chaired all
the main protest events in the sit in
the streets in recent months this is a
google translation that's why the syntax
is sort of weird
the protest comrades gave the news of
their leaders death on facebook without
ever mentioning the cause
news like that of the death of our
beloved luigi marilli a member of the
national direction of liberal italia one
of the founders of the liberation march
and spokesman they write in a note are
those that would never want to receive
his strength of mind testified by the
tireless activity of guiding and
coordinating the abruzzo committee and
the other resistance forces came from
the certainty and pride of always
fighting for justice equality freedom it
never mentions
what actually happened and if you scroll
through the comments you see a post from
his friend mourinho retchitti who says
he died of covet
he died of covet
this is
not a joke guys this is a very serious
situation
and you have not only casually
anti-vaccine people like the right-wing
radio host who is like yeah i'm not
getting vaccinated i don't need that and
then they get sick and then they die
this is a long time anti-vaccine leader
now does it make it more tragic that
this was an anti-vaccine leader no it
doesn't make it more tragic but it
should just serve as a stark reminder
that your opinions really don't matter
we've got a bell curve
and there are a lot of people in the
middle of that bell curve who will sort
of get a little sick and then recover
and then you've got people at one end of
the bell curve who just will never get
it even despite multiple exposures or
they'll be asymptomatic and then on the
other side of the bell curve you've got
people who are going to die from this
and they might be anti-vaxx as a career
like this guy and it doesn't matter um
it's not something i point and laugh at
but we should remember
that for all of these different groups
that spread the disinformation it's not
only the
unvaccinated that are dying it's the
anti-vax activists that are dying as
well this was a well-known guy who was
known in the anti-vaxx community of
italy and he has now died of covid uh
we'll have more on this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show this is super interesting um many
of you know about republican congressman
kevin mccarthy now kevin mccarthy is a
guy who back around the trump riots was
speaking regularly
not only with donald trump but with
other people in that circle and cnn has
unearthed audio of kevin mccarthy saying
i spoke to trump
and trump admitted he has some
responsibility for the riots to me now
why is this relevant it's relevant
because for the last year plus now year
and two weeks almost to the day
donald trump and people around him have
been
denying that trump had anything to do
with what ultimately took place
and or saying
it was peaceful
and or saying the violence was antifa so
all of those different things conflict
some of them cancel each other out
doesn't matter the point is they've gone
out of their way to say
trump there's no responsibility here for
trump whatsoever for what happened on
january 6th and yet and yet cnn unearths
audio of kevin mccarthy saying trump
admitted responsibility for the riot
cnn's k file resurfaced the top house
republicans comments to a california
radio station days after the january 6th
insurrection
um let's just listen to the audio take a
listen to exactly what kevin mccarthy
said i say he has responsibility he told
me personally that he does have some
responsibility i think a lot of people
do but what i proposed which i think
history will say i'm right because it's
the right thing to do i believe
have a bipartisan commission and get all
your facts
actually work through the grand jury to
find out at the end instead of
pre-determining whether someone's guilty
or not pretty wow i mean it's not only a
good idea have a special committee do a
special investigation well it's
happening now and republicans are
essentially completely opposed to it but
kevin mccarthy clearly says
i believe trump has some responsibility
and trump admitted to me that he has
some responsibility this has been
completely buried now kevin mccarthy was
more recently asked about it he forgot
guys he doesn't remember kevin mccarthy
says he doesn't remember the phone call
where trump admitted some responsibility
days after january 6
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
told other republicans in a phone call
that trump claimed some responsibility
for the capitol riot according to cnn
but during a news conference thursday
mccarthy said he couldn't recall the
phone call uh here is kevin mccarthy
asked about it check this out
did you tell house republicans on a
january 11 phone call that president
trump told you he agreed that he for
some responsibility for january 6 as
chairman thompson's letter indicates
i'm not sure what call you're talking
about
oh and then he goes on to a different
reporter now notice the very specific
language i don't know what call you were
talking about that's a very different
answer than i have never said nor
believed trump admitted responsibility
nor is responsible so if someone said to
me
did you say that and i go i don't know
what phone call you're talking about
it's not a denial
right sort of like if someone says hey
did you um
did did you call and threaten
to uh steal pizza from a pizza hut
and i go
i don't know what phone call you're
referring to that's a very different
answer than i've never called pizza hut
and threatened to steal pizza these are
two very very different reactions and
kevin mccarthy
listen if you have to guess what the
truth is the truth is at the time it
wasn't yet clear that for a year trump
and the people around him would deny
that he had anything to do with the riot
so kevin mccarthy said it
uh in early january mid-january of 2021
and meant it and it was true
and now in retrospect it would look very
very bad for mccarthy to say this last
year of trump and everybody around him
pretending like he had nothing to do
with it and there's nothing to see here
well a year ago trump admitted to me
that he had some responsibility that
would look very very bad for trump and
it would probably put kevin mccarthy in
the doghouse so i believe that trump did
say it i believe mccarthy uh did report
it at the time
and now he's just lying and it's such a
technical and specific answer i don't
know what phone call you are referring
to is a world away
from i've never said it because trump
never said it to me and i don't believe
that he bears any responsibility those
are dramatically different things
um when we talk about 2022 and i do
believe we are now officially in the
midterm
uh period you know we've been talking
before about usually the midterms really
heat up in june or july and
this time around it might be may it
might even be late april i believe that
with the start of trump's 2022 rallies
over the weekend and just with the
amount of interest and discussion that's
already taking place about specific 2022
races including dr oz
i'm sorry mehmet oz i'm i'm doing it too
we need mehmet oz running in in
pennsylvania um with the discussions
about what appear to be shoeing
trumpists that will easily sail to
reelection you know many of their names
i won't repeat them it seems pretty
clear that the 2022 midterms have begun
and
one of the reasons that the 2022
midterms are important are that if
republicans take the house in 2022 the
investigation into the trump riots is
over so there's urgency for it to be
completed before the november elections
that's number one number two the success
of trump endorses in 2022
may well be a signal
about
2024 in terms of trump's interest in
running trump's likelihood in running
okay that's another reason
but there's a third really important
category as to why 2022 matters which is
depending on what happens in 2022 not
only in the house and senate but very
importantly in in races within states
governors
secretaries of state and here we go now
election supervisors the republican
party may be in a better position in
2024
to successfully steal an election they
unsuccessfully tried to steal an
election in 2020 depending on what
happens in 2022 they may be in a real
position
to actually succeed at stealing an
election in 2024 and we have video here
of donald trump just admitting it
uh this is video and remember
they tried with raffensberger in georgia
and it didn't work
but had different people been there in
georgia it might actually have worked so
here donald trump in a video message to
the pennsylvania republican party
he explains why
he is focusing on supervisor of
elections races in 2022 he's admitting
the strategy out loud my friends take a
look at this it'll be a lot sharper the
next time when it comes to counting the
vote there's a famous statement
sometimes the
vote counter is more important than the
candidate and we can't let that ever
ever happen again they have to get
tougher and smarter so when trump says
we need tougher and smarter people
counting the ballots running elections
what he's saying is
we need to more effectively
put our people in control of elections
so that when i lose
um i can just have someone
figure out a way to make me win remember
him demanding the 11 000 votes
i need 11 000 votes give me a break
right that was with georgia so we've
known that this is the strategy
and donald trump is admitting that this
is the strategy and this is one of the
major reasons why donald trump is going
to be so involved in the 2022 races they
are going to try again and remember
we've we've gone through these different
scenarios if trump had had some
friendlier people
in three or four states it's not a
guarantee that it would have gone a
different way but it would have
significantly upped the odds that even
though trump lost
he might have been able to stay in power
it upped the odds i'm not saying it made
it likely but it upped the odds if
raffensberger had been willing
could it flip georgia right i mean at
the end of the day
11 000 votes as donald trump said uh
we've now heard from retired generals
from the military who have warned and
said
if
the military brass
had been willing and interested in
helping
you could have had the assistance of the
military in carrying out the coup
trump didn't have it in 2020. what if
that changed and there is no doubt
whatsoever where this is heading joseph
stalin said in 1923
quote i consider it completely
unimportant who in the party will vote
or how
but what is extraordinarily important is
this
who will count the votes
and how
and he is saying
that he wants them to be better at
stealing elections period and so
how do we i i've talked before about the
difficulty of playing defense against
this
they might have 12 strategies
and we need to know all 12 and know how
to defend against them we might only
know how to defend against eleven and
that twelfth strategy is what could be
the difference maker so they're doing
gerrymandering of course for help at the
state level
they are working on voter suppression
closing polling places restricting early
voting hours strategically all of these
different things
voter roll purges on you know the full
list
and now
openly saying
we need our supervisors of elections in
place
in order to
make this
more plausible
that we would succeed next time and this
is part of why 2022 is so important i
hope
that the left understands the importance
of 2022
midterms
that always you know compared to general
elections midterms have lower turnout
and it's so
kind of cliche and um uh
i don't know what other word to apply to
it to say
these are
very important midterms particularly
important midterms and there's always
some reason why someone will say this is
the most important election
in a very specific sense which is when
it comes to trying to steal the
elections when they don't win
2022
could be the rubicon where once it is
crossed it will be very very difficult
to go back and so
we are going to be getting back into
you've got to vote you've got to vote
and i know it became a broken record
leading up to the 2020 election but
everyone must vote not just because if
republicans take control of the house
and senate it will be a disaster for the
united states not just because trumpian
candidates winning makes it more likely
trump runs in 2024 and quite frankly i
think
i think trump in 24 beats joe biden or
kamala i've said that before some of you
agree some of you disagree but also
because 2022 is going to be part of the
plan
for better positioning themselves to
steal future elections which would be an
absolute and total nightmare we're going
to take a break and be back with some
very interesting news headlines your
voicemail and so many other things stay
with us we will be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right a big story breaking this
morning about the january 6th
investigation it happens to be really
bad news for the trump family eric trump
as well as kimberly guilfoyle's phone
records have been subpoenaed and
reportedly obtained by the january 6
committee again pushing forward into the
inner circle around trump and
theoretically eventually to trump
himself eric trump is one of trump's
sons kimberly guilfoyle is the fiancee
of don jr and their records now are
becoming part of the investigation cnn
reporting exclusive eric trump and
kimberly guilfoyle's phone records
subpoenaed by the january 6th committee
the house committee investigating the
january sixth attack on the capital has
subpoenaed and obtained records of phone
numbers associated with one of former
trump's children eric trump as well as
kimberly guilfoyle it appears to be the
first time the select committee has
issued a subpoena that targeted a member
of the trump family in what marks a
significant escalation of the
investigation into trump's role in the
january 6th insurrection the decision to
subpoena communication records involving
the trump family
underscores the aggressive tack the
committee is taking as it races to
complete its investigation while
battling trump in court over access to
documents the phone records obtained by
the committee are part of a new round of
call detail records
these records provide the committee with
logs that show incoming and outgoing
calls including date time and length of
calls the records show a log of text
messages but not necessarily the
substance or content this is fascinating
because this is this is that the
so-called metadata and um one of the
things that we learned from edward
snowden's
exposures are about practices of bulk
metadata collection and one of the
things that the right has been very
quick to say
some on the right who want to defend uh
government surveillance not not all of
them do the libertarian minded ones
don't but sometimes they say listen this
is just metadata after all it's not
actually the substance and the content
it's not recordings of calls or the
text of text messages well that's what's
here
that's what we're talking about here
and they are flipping out because they
have done this with regard to eric trump
and kimberly guilfoyle uh both eric
trump and guilfoyle played prominent
roles in trump's stop the steel efforts
including guild guilfoyle fundraising
off of the lie that the election was
stolen they both spoke on the january 6
rally that led to the attack on the
capital
the records may help the committee flesh
out text messages and phone records from
others like mark meadows fundraisers and
rally organizers
cnn reported last month that the
committee already subpoenaed phone
records of more than a hundred different
people
the newly obtained records include the
cell phone number used by eric trump the
cell phone number for guilfoyle was
confirmed by sources familiar with her
number and texts the committee
previously identified the number as
guilfoyle so they already knew that
there is no indication the committee has
directly subpoenaed either eric trump or
guilfoyle for interviews or documents
nor is there any evidence that the
committee subpoenaed records related to
trump's other kids ivanka don jr or
son-in-law jared kushner now
ivanka and junior and jared
they can't really be far behind is my
instinct on this
and
trump's
relationship you know the same way that
trump doesn't seem to understand like
how to relate to dogs to pets it's just
this weird kind of thing there's a
similar thing with trump's kids that
we've noticed i'm not even sure
that trump would be that upset
if his kids went to prison to save his
ass
uh i think he would
be sort of embarrassed because of how it
would look
but it doesn't really seem he would care
that much and as far as the timing of
the investigation
understand as i said earlier in thinking
about 2022
this committee ends if democrats lose
the house in november made effective in
january when the new house gets sworn in
so at the current pace
the idea would be
they are done before the midterms
i
you know when we talk about an october
surprise
it's completely plausible
that the investigation will be done
before the midterms and that there would
be some major report
with takeaways and it would be an
october surprise
i just have a hard time imagining that
it would affect the elections i don't
think whatever comes out of this is
going to change anybody's minds because
if the committee determines
trump was responsible and here's all the
people that coke you know coke
that's already what we intuitively
believe
based on everything we know so far and
everything that's public
and the republicans don't care they
would re-elect them like that most of
them would anyway so
on the one hand the timing of the
election makes it important for this to
be completed in time at the same time
it's hard to imagine anything that comes
out of this that actually affects the
midterms if you disagree with me if you
think there's something that could
actually affect the midterms and change
people's minds who would otherwise vote
for these trumpian republicans
let me know and um the the sort of last
piece of this is
imagine
that the january 6th committee
um
finds evidence of criminality
and turns it over to the to the to the
department of justice
it would take months
at minimum after the release of the
report
for the doj
to investigate
and then to charge anybody so the timing
of that also would not end up affecting
the 2022 midterm so
on the one hand this is incredibly
important work that must be done and i
want it to be completed in a reasonable
amount of time
on the other hand it's more for the
historical record quite frankly and
maybe for its use in 2024 if trump does
run again
than it is for
affecting the 2022 midterms if you
disagree and if you believe there is a
way that this report would actually
influence the midterms let me know you
can email info
davidpakman.com
on the tuesday show we talked about the
undeniable reality that with the start
of trump rallies um this past weekend
in support of 2022 candidates the 2022
midterms have sort of officially they've
unofficially officially begun uh we are
now the rallies are starting it's all
starting to happen but there's another
election
that i normally would not be talking
about right now but i don't think i have
a choice because it's very clear has
also officially begun the 2024
republican primary has begun how can you
tell you can tell because donald trump
and republican florida governor ron
desantis who previously were buddies
united around covid and we're all for
freedom and ron's doing a great job
opening up for wwe and ufc when
everything else is closed early in the
pandemic they're now attacking each
other and pretty brutally and trump has
even started to send his cronies like
roger stone to attack ron desantis why
ron desantis because ron desantis is
donald trump's primary challenger right
now based on polling for 2022. so let's
go through this uh piece by piece
axios has a report
trump dogs dull desantis
ahead of potential 2024 matchup this is
from jonathan swann
donald trump is trashing ron desantis in
private as an ingrate with a dull
personality and no realistic chance of
beating him in a potential 2024 showdown
according to sources who have recently
talked to trump about desantis why it
matters the two are among the most
popular republicans in the country
as the former president eyes a 2024 run
he is irked by desantis's popularity and
refusal to rule out running against
trump desantis is a favorite of
republican voters when pollsters remove
trump
the governor also hasn't been beyond
tweaking his fellow floridian desantis
said on the ruthless podcast one of his
biggest regrets was not speaking out
much louder
in march of 2020 when trump advised the
american public to stay home
um
this is accurate in the sen what i mean
is
trump correctly sees desantis as his
biggest foe
for 2024
as of right now we had the cpac straw
poll over the summer
donald trump topped everybody else with
70
but in second place was desantis with 21
that's an informal survey when you look
at the betting markets where people can
bet
who will win the 2024 republican
presidential nomination right now
37 cents of every dollar are being bet
on donald trump and 28 cents of every
dollar are being bet on ron desantis
that's a smaller gap
than the straw poll in july suggested we
also have so-called real polling there's
a harvard caps
harris poll from two months ago where
donald trump was polling 47 percent
among registered republicans and
independents in the primary poll
and that was very far ahead of desantis
who was at 10 percent but again
everywhere you look ron desantis is
running second sometimes it's a pretty
distant second sometimes it's a pretty
strong second so now
trump is starting the attacks and so are
trump's cronies remember this from last
week here is donald trump in his
interview with oan
calling out ron desantis he doesn't say
his name he doesn't say his name but
it's abundantly clear that he's talking
about ron desantis here as someone who
has gotten the booster and won't admit
it it's something out there
but after now so many months of the
vaccine being administered and these
side effects and americans questions of
it
do you reconsider your push for it or
what's your view now on the vaccine in
general well i've taken it i've had the
booster
many politicians i watched a couple of
politicians be interviewed
and one of the questions was did you get
the booster now that that he's talking
about desantis here there's no question
because they had the vaccine
and they oh they're answering it like in
other words the answer is yes but they
don't want to say it
because they're gutless you gotta say it
whether you had it or not say it
but the fact so that is an indirect
attack on ron desantis
um and then also roger stone
has been uh going on uh uh going out
there as trump's uh kind of lap dog for
lack of a better term roger stone
publishing to i think this was on uh
getter or rumble or i don't who the hell
knows
roger stone saying trump sometimes
sometimes president donald trump hits it
right on the nose ron desantis yale
harvard fat boy can't get out of his own
way not smart
not honest and not going to be president
an unknown congressman with a bad
haircut and an ill-fitting suit until
donald trump made him governor i know
where he was when he was missing ask
emerald robinson that's a reference of
course to
when ron desantis was mia for two weeks
in the sort of middle to end of december
of last year we covered that uh ron
desantis also
uh being attacked by roger stone in a
new video that has been released my beef
with governor ron desantis
ron desantis was an unknown congressman
with a bad haircut
an ill-fitting suit and an
undistinguished record in congress until
president donald trump's endorsement
lifted him to the republican nomination
for governor of florida and then
because ron is such a boring and poor
candidate president donald trump with
the able assistance of susie wiles had
to visit florida twice to drag ron over
the finish line to become governor of
florida
now governor ron desantis refuses to put
his own presidential ambitions on hold
until president donald trump has decided
whether he wants to run again so that's
interesting it's what roger stone is
saying is that the correct thing to do
the respectful thing to do to show
deference to trump would be for ron
desantis to say
this is donald trump's
uh nomination
to turn down
i'm not ruling anything out
but i would not run against him that
would be what roger stone believes would
be respectful i consider that to be an
incredible act of disloyalty and
ingratitude
governor desantis says that i'm a
convicted felon well actually i'm a
former convicted felon thanks to the
pardon by donald trump but if ron
desantis isn't careful he will soon be a
former governor of florida without the
active support of president donald trump
so that's a reference to 2022 because
remember that one of the most
interesting
2022
gubernatorial races
is uh that of ron desantis right and i
don't i want to make sure i'm not
getting that wrong i'd be ron desantis
ron desantis 2022
campaign
um
yes okay yes ron desantis is running um
he's up for reelection in 20 just making
sure i get that right so why are they so
aggressively going after desantis
because they see desantis as a threat
it's very clear that this is 2024
posturing it is not only the trump side
attacking desantis as i told you before
ron desantis saying he wishes that
earlier he would have pushed back
against the things that donald trump was
doing and saying early in the pandemic
mr descen new york times reporting mr
desantis shot back friday criticizing
trump's early handling of the pandemic
and saying he regretted not being more
vocal in his complaints
um this is potentially
a fascinating showdown in 2024
and my priority in it is not just the
kind of disaster porn of a really ugly
trump versus desantis primary i would
love that from an entertainment
perspective but at the same time going
from the entertainment side to the to
the important practical matter
i think 2024 is going to be really tough
for democrats if it's trump versus biden
i think trump wins
if it's trump versus kamala harris i
think trump wins if it's desantis versus
biden
i feel less strongly but i still would
lean towards the santa i mean i think
there's a real uphill battle here and of
course there's a lot that needs to
happen the 2022 midterms two more years
of governing and then we will see
but i'm not feeling thrilled about any
of this so what i'm hoping for is that a
really ugly republican primary damages
whoever is the eventual nominee we're
getting very very far ahead of ourselves
but that's the thought process right now
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
you can call absolutely any time this is
so funny this is almost beyond parody
you guys if you've been listening for a
while might be aware of all of the
different anti-vaccine people that
regularly call in one such person is
this guy eric from massachusetts he's
been calling in for two years every one
of his predictions is wrong
he cites non-existent data he says this
about the vaccines that about the
vaccines his new thing is that they're
about to close the vaccines like a
dollar store might close at 10 the
vaccines are about to close he says take
a listen to this
hey david it's eric from math uh what
are you going to do
when the uh vaccines are pulled because
that's what's gonna happen next
they're just gonna be closed down
they're closing them down i've been
right about everything i told you he has
not been right about anything he has
said by the way i'm wrong but i'm right
and what will you do how will you back
that or what would you say
um you're gonna have to admit you're
paid off by pharma that's what
we we have received no money from uh big
pharma that that is uh if if anyone
wants to try to prove otherwise which
you would fail to do
um democrats don't pay us big pharma
doesn't pay us george soros doesn't pay
they're not paying us
why would they they have no reason to
i'm just wondering do you have a backup
plan because this
website thing you got going on is
about to crumble right
that's what we call the circling the
drain meme
for the last 15 years every day you can
find at least one youtube comment saying
wow
this show is almost completely dead and
every month we are bigger than we were
the month before it's it's quite
remarkable that they're still repeating
that one so no the vaccines are not
going to be closed they are going to
remain open um on the bonus show today
the website to get free coveted tests
delivered to your home is up and running
i've ordered
mine we'll tell you how to order yours
when they're going to be going out
puerto rico has gotten the green light
to end
its five-year bankruptcy we will talk
about what's going on
and the supreme court is having quite an
anti-mask problem uh trump appointee
neil gorsuch
just ignored a request from the chief
justice john roberts for him to wear a
mask out of respect for justice sonia
sotomayor
what is going on and why is neil gorsuch
such a vile person we will talk about it
on today's bonus show you can get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpakman.com
don't miss it every day you get the
bonus show as a member you get six hours
earlier than everybody else a commercial
free full episode of the show don't wait
till 9 pm eastern or for clips to
publish
become a member you'll get the show six
hours earlier
sign up at joinpacman.com and i will see
you on the bonus show